Psychologists look at stress with two different vantage points. Stress as a
stimulus and stress as a response. First, we have stress as a stimulus. This
looks at stress as the result of a particular stimulus. Here we're saying that
stress is the result of a stressor. In other words, an event that triggers
stress. In the example we discussed earlier, the stressor could be the ten page
paper that needs to be written. Another example would be writing a check that
you realize that you don't have the money in your bank account to cover, or
getting in an argument with your roommate, or friend. Any of those things could
be stressors. The idea here, is that a situation causes stress. The other
advantage point from which psychologists use stress is stress as a response.
Here psychologists look at the physiological changes or reactions that happen
when we encounter a stressful situation. Think of this as what's happening
inside of your body when we're stressed. Here, we'll see things that happen in
a body when we experience acute stress, as well as chronic long term exposure
to stress. Stress as a stimulus looks at what causes the stress and stress as a
response looks at how the body responds to stress, when we're stressed. But
let's go to Susan to start with examining stress as a stimulus.